The second Fantastic Beasts film brings together
the story of Newt Scamander and his old professor
Albus Dumbledore.
Throughout, fans can find a ton of Easter
eggs hidden throughout the picture that only
the truest Harry Potter aficionados are bound
to catch.
Pull out your wand, and get your anti-spoiler
spell ready: here are the small details you
missed in Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of
Grindelwald.
In The Crimes of Grindelwald, there's a lot
to unpack about the relationship between the
titular villain and his opposite-equal, Albus
Dumbledore.
Dumbledore's visit to the Mirror of Erised
does help reveal some of the major points:
In it, he sees his younger self making a blood
pact with the boy he says he was "closer than
brothers" with.
Not only does that call back a similar scene
from Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
when the Boy Wizard summons up a happier image
of his parents, it also earns a more subtle
bit of nostalgia from the original series
thanks to who we see in it.
Actors Toby Regbo and Jamie Campbell Bower
reprise their roles as Dumbledore and Grindelwald
in Fantastic Beasts 2, after having portrayed
the characters ever so briefly in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows: Part 1.
Considering how small their screen time was
in the original series, they could've easily
been replaced, but seeing them return to these
roles nicely bridges the gap between the film
sets.
The sweeping new shots of an unfettered Hogwarts
probably made for a very welcome sight for
Harry Potter fans who cringed with every artifact's
destruction in the Second Wizarding War in
Deathly Hallows: Part 2.
The bridge is shown intact, the Great Hall
is perfectly lit by floating candles, and,
of course, Dumbledore's office is still filled
with so many of his intriguing tools of the
trade.
The scenes involving young Dumbledore also
featured a few namedrops that will ring familiar
to fans.
First, there's the instruction for the students
to go with Professor McGonagall, who we all
know and love so well from the Harry Potter
series.
Then, one student's name is called out as
Mclaggen, who must be the ancestor of this
Gryffindor student from the original series,
Cormac McLaggen.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
also turned what we knew about an old Harry
Potter character on its head when it revealed
that Nagini was not always the snake sidekick
of the Dark Lord.
Instead, she was formerly a person with the
Maledictus curse, which meant that she shape-shifted
into snake form and one day would not be able
to change back.
There's a running theory that she might turn
out to be Tom Riddle's actual mother before
it's all said and done.
It would certainly help explain the allegiance
she develops for the character later on — not
to mention his eventual snakey features and
his gift with parseltongue — especially
if she were to, say, conceive Voldemort with
Credence.
On the other hand, the books and films have
already established Riddle's parentage, so
if the Fantastic Beasts films decide to go
a different direction, they'll have a whole
lot of explaining to do.
Harry Potter fans may have previously only
known of Nicholas Flamel thanks to Harry,
Hermione, and Ron discovering how he created
the Philosopher's Stone and achieved immortality
— or at least really, really long life — in
the first installment.
However, Fantastic Beasts 2 gives us a fuller
glimpse of the character in his crone-like
decrepit form — as well as a quick glimpse
of that elusive Philospher's Stone in Flamel's
house.
But unlike most of Rowling's characters, Flamel
was actually a real person, and was rumored
to have used alchemy to become immortal.
"Nickola Flamel.”
“Jacob Kowalski.”
“Oh!”
"You don’t look a day over 375.”
The end of Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of
Grindelwald features a big twist, where we
finally learn about Credence's family history.
After narrowly escaping capture in the first
film, he spends this movie trying to track
down the identity of his real parents and
figure out why they decided to leave him in
the care of a horrible woman like Mary Lou
Barebone.
In the end, he discovers that he isn't the
long-lost sibling of Leta LeStrange, as he'd
expected, but that he was actually named Aurelius
Dumbledore — and that Albus Dumbledore is
trying to destroy him, according to Grindelwald.
If there's one thing these Wizarding World
stories love, it's family drama, and the revelation
that Credence could actually be related to
Dumbledore is the good stuff.
Fans of the franchise are probably poring
over their books to see if they can figure
out where this new information fits into the
ever-expanding Harry Potter universe.
If only hearing the actors say the name "Dumbledore"
with such gravitas didn't sound quite so,
well…
"Ridikkulus."